well I actually didn't wrote maybe the
reason for that is I was expecting the
vote to go with let's stay in which I
expected everybody because everybody
around me was saying of course we'll
stay in I would hope but a lot of people
that have voted leave now have seen what
the consequences are and maybe there'll
be another little wrote a little bit
more positive information around for
people to make up a different choice
maybe with more informational knowledge
it's a complete mess as people resigning
everywhere people have talked about this
all kinds of stories left right and
center nobody really knows it's an aunt
Elizabeth a big things gone off
somewhere and everybody's reeling from
it and read nobody knows where to where
to pick up and how to get on with things
nobody knows what's next nobody seems to
know what's going to happen what what
what the time scale is what's round the
corner we know he knows where to Los